so if you have trouble consuming nuts
this video is for you whether you're
consuming almonds pecans brazil nuts so
a lot of people get this bloating and
they're not sure why well nuts have more
phytic acid
than even grains or legumes but what is
this thing called phytic acid
phytic acid is something that a seed
uses to help bind minerals and prevent
biochemical reactions to allow this seed
to sprout so phytic acid is kind of a
chemical to keep things locked up and
when you consume seeds with phytic acid
you are not only creating a problem in
the absorption of calcium iron magnesium
zinc
copper
but also because some of those minerals
are used in enzymes
overall when you consume nuts you can't
utilize a lot of these enzymes to help
you digest them so
it's a situation where you're consuming
a food without the enzymes and so it
tends to
sit in the stomach create all sorts of
bloating create irritation and even
inflammation so the worst nut that has
the highest phytic acid is almonds it is
9.4 percent phytic acid
walnuts are six point seven percent
phytic acid
and brazil nuts are six point three
percent
now if you compare these two grains
grains are actually a lot less but
there's a very simple solution to phytic
acid all you have to do is mimic the
normal
sprouting process or germination process
that naturally occurs when you plant a
seed and to do that you just soak them
in water overnight that will start the
process going the phytic acid will be
released
this whole binding process between
minerals will go away so you can
actually absorb these minerals and now
this nut is going to be much easier to
digest now the problem is you can have
this silky soggy wet nut so you're gonna
have to dry it out and the best way to
do that is either put it in the oven at
a very low temperature
or a dehydrator for a period of time
until it's dry but what you're going to
find is when you germinate
nuts and seeds
and dry them out the taste is much
better the nutrition is way way better
and they're just much easier to digest
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others